and finally new rule if someone knows of
a story that more effectively captures
what's wrong with today's journalism
than the sad saga of what happened last
week at the washington post
they need to keep it to themselves
because it would be too
depressing if you missed it the
washington post recently got embroiled
in a self-inflicted [ __ ] storm when one
of their best reporters david weigel
retweeted not tweeted retweeted this
joke
every girl is bi
you just have to figure out if it's
polar or sexual
proving it is a joke thank you
the comedian who actually wrote the
tweet called it a banal throwaway joke
which is exactly what it is throw away
as and if you don't like it throw it
away
for eons both sexes have made jokes
about how the other is crazy and no one
but the perpetually offended thinks it
means anything more than that the sexes
get frustrated over how differently we
each see the world
and yes we relieve some of that
frustration with humor
and scene
nevertheless
weigel pulled down his retweet and wrote
i apologize and did not mean to cause
any harm and that was the end of that
i'm joking of course
the unlicensed daycare center that is
today's newsroom went ape [ __ ]
you see the post has another writer
named felicia sanmez and she's a lot
for example she tweeted about kobe
bryant's 2003 rape trial hours after his
helicopter crash
and despite the fact that she says dave
weigel is a good friend she resurrected
the tweet he had taken down with the
screenshot and demanded to know what the
post was going to do about this
unacceptable evil that must not be
allowed to stand
sarcastically writing
fantastic to work at a news outlet where
tweets like this are allowed
yes can you imagine a world that allows
jokes you don't like
of course
of course the leadership at the post
folded like a miami condo and
and suspended weigel without pay for a
month and denounced the offending
retweet as a gross violation of their
values free speech apparently not being
one of them
then a third post reporter offered up
the idea of course on twitter because
why do anything privately
that hey maybe everyone was overreacting
and we should all just calm down
and then it was really on
felicia demanded that the post
discipline him
and tweeted about that
i assume she's tweeting about this right
now
for days she raged with the fire of a
thousand burning bras
a gazillion tweets calling for more to
be done against weigel mocking her
bosses attacking colleagues and letting
the world know how much the washington
post sucked and this endless bickering
and infighting continued online in
public view
until the bell rang and they all went to
seventh period
[Applause]
now note that i haven't yet told you
what age felicia sonmez and her
quarreling co-workers are why
because i didn't have to
because you can't imagine someone my age
acting like this in an office
the new york times just ran an op-ed
entitled why are we still governed by
baby boomers this is why
because too many millennials
are overly sensitive overly fragile and
have no sense of priorities you know i'm
sure many boomers would love to retire
but they can't they're like the
grandmother who'd much rather be
watching judge judy but has to raise her
grandkids because her own kids are too
[ __ ] up to manage it
it's funny you think my generation is an
eye roll let me live on a little secret
about the younger generations no one
wants to hire you
your sense of entitlement is legendary
and
with notable exceptions
your attention span and worth ethics
suck
here's a story you never stop hearing
around hollywood
unqualified little [ __ ] who has been
here all of six months doesn't
understand why he's not a producer yet
this washington post story had such
resonance because its behavior we all
recognize
there is a war going on within the
millennial generation i know because i'm
friends with the good ones
but the cry babies unfortunately are
still winning
they complain they haven't taken over
yet well stop complaining because in
many ways you already have the fact that
the post's initial response
was to punish not felicia but one of
their best reporters for a silly joke
shows that the kindergarten is already
in charge
today today june 17th is the 50th
anniversary of a very seminal event in
american history on this day in 1972 the
watergate break-in happened
and over the next two years the
washington post gave the world a master
class in investigative journalism
i have to wonder how the post's newsroom
of today would handle that story
or how they're currently handling any
story all this time blubber tweeting
over a retweet begs the question don't
you have anything better to do
aren't you uh supposed to be reporters
digging up stuff
are there no more vital issues going on
in america right now this is why you're
not in charge because if someone named
deep throat called the paper today and
wanted to meet in a parking garage
this crew of emotional hemophiliacs
would have an anxiety attack and
report it to hr that they didn't feel
safe
[Applause]
if there is a silver lining to this
story it's that eventually the post did
fire felicia sanmez so maybe there is a
line that's just too much nonsense but
that generation needs to move that line
much closer to sanity and find it much
sooner because democracy
dies in dumbness
you